ja es handelt sich erstmal nicht mal um
ein zelt und zwar handelt es sich um das
zelt der familie tränkler wir sprechen
gleich mit frau trenkler die davon
betroffen ist ja vor wenigen minuten
waren noch die feuerwehr hier 20
einsatzkräfte waren hier im einsatz
wirklich da hat jeder mitgeholfen um
diese schneemassen von diesem zelt zu
befreien die tiere waren fünf stunden
lang eingeschlossen und wir müssen sagen
den tieren geht es gut
dieses t coesfeld darunter sind seit
acht monaten lang zwölf tiere
untergebracht weil dieser zirkus hier
gestrandet ist und wir sprechen jetzt
mit tatiana trenkler hier sie ungehört
das zirkus vegetieren und das ist genau
passiert also wir gemerkt haben unser
tierzelt ist eingebrochen
durch die hunde des quelle haben
herausgerückt war das tierzelt total
eingebrochen
der erste gedanke war wie geht es
unseren tieren aber gott sei dank
unseren tieren geht es gut kein tier ist
verletzt und das ist für uns die erste
stelle wo wir denken
super dass es unseren tieren gut geht
das zweite war das ganze stallzelt war
ja fast auf der erde gelegen mussten die
feuerwehr um hilfe bitten weil wir es
nicht alleine geschafft haben das
tierzelt hat jetzt mehrere risse wir
wissen nicht ob es weiter den stand
überhaupt hält weiß und hier zählt ist
ja gerade nicht mehr günstig das liegt
ja zwischen 12 bis 15.000 euro für eine
neuanschaffung und die haben wir nicht
wir haben ja auch die bürger hier
gefragt ob die irgendwo ein grundstück
für uns haben wurde der zirkus
überwintern kann und die hilfe brauchen
wir immer noch um wer uns helfen möchte
finanziell der kann sich auch hierbei
familie tränkler circus verona sehr
gerne herzlich bei uns melden jetzt
sind sie ja schon seit acht monaten hier
und sind seit über 50 jahren im zirkus
geschäft tätig hatten sie schon mal so
einen winter erlebt nein also ich selbst
nicht vielleicht die verwandten vorher
oder familie aber von erzähle rey sowas
haben wir noch nicht erlebt dass unser
tierzelt eingestürzt ist
und ja es ist hier zählt ist ja jetzt
überall beschädigt kaputt wir wissen
auch nicht ob es weiter den standhält
sie sehen ja selbst wie tief das noch
abgesagt ist das tierzelt es ist jetzt
erst mal provisorisch hoch gestellt
worden von der feuerwehr von uns sie
sehen wie das wetter ist wir haben angst
dass das tierzelt wieder einbricht und
das ist ja nicht mehr jetzt im stand wie
es vorher war
wir müssen gucken wo kriegen wir neues
tier zeigte aber wenn keine einnahme und
das ist vom was sollen wir das bezahlen
wir schauen gleich auch noch mal rein
ich erkläre es nochmal wie das ganze
passieren konnte also auf dieses feld
200 quadratmeter groß 20 mal 10 meter
haben sich eine dicke schneeschicht
darauf bewegt das ganze ist vereist und
ist dann komplett in sich gestürzt
schauen hier die seile die gurte die
hier befestigt sind sind auch komplett
vereist und die musste die feuerwehr
erst mal mit wir haben klar werfer
erstmal enteisen um wieder spannung hier
rein zu bekommen und wir gehen jetzt mal
ein zelt und schauen uns mal innen drin
an da werden noch die letzten
weil es hier auch eingeschneit die tiere
waren fünf stunden lang eingeschlossen
hier im hinteren feld
wir werden noch die letzten schneereste
entfernt ja vor trenkler wie haben die
tiere reagierten sie das nochmal sagen
also ich sag mal haben für sich haben
unsere tiere sehr gut reagiert klar was
ist jetzt los merken die tiere auch aber
gott sei dank unseren tieren geht es gut
das sehen sie ja alle sind fit auf und
das ist für uns an erster stelle dass
sich die szene
vielen dank erstmal finanztitel ja und
der familie war es ganz wichtig dass es
den tieren gut geht immer wieder sind
die listen die familie möchte ja so die
zirkus mitglieder hier eingegangen haben
die tiere versorgt und geguckt ob alles
in ordnung ist und ja jetzt blickt man
die ganze zeit später und hofft dass das
ganze sich nicht noch mal wiederholt
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren